Металолом! Його можна приватизувати?
Застарілий морально та фізично.
І це це столичне локомотивне депо.
А що робиться в глибинці?
Так емоційно голова Вільної профспілки залізничників України
Володимир Козельський реагує на наміри уряду Олексія Гончарука
приватизувати "Укрзалізницю".
Він усі роки незалежності чекає на ефективні реформи.
Але категорично проти приватизації "Укрзалізниці",
яка  стала можливою після того, як Верховна Рада
виключила її зі списку об’єктів, що не підлягають приватизації.
За планом уряду, залізниця буде поділена на три окремих підприємства.
Одне займатиметься вантажними перевезеннями, друге - пасажирськими.
Третє має залишитися повністю в державній власності і займатися інфраструктурою.
Провести приватизацію уряд планує якомога швидше – за рік.
Володимиру Козельському цей поспіх зовсім не подобається.
От-тако безглуздо розбивати на компанії.
А перед цим ми ділили депо, ділили залізниці,
знищували виробничі підрозділи. Непонятка йде.
Якось реформа має йти, стратегія виписана.
Приходить один уряд чи президент - пишуть одну стратегію наші керівники залізниці,
Приходять інші - пишуть другу. Є хаос.
Треба якось брати досвід за кордоном.
Навряд чи за кордоном можна знайти досвід приватизації
такого великого залізничного підприємства в напівзруйнованому стані.
Утім, уряд впевнений, що зможе побудувати логістику приватизації так,
аби створити конкурентний ринок, на якому заробляли б і державні, і приватні підприємства,
а надходження в бюджет з використання залізничної інфраструктури збільшувалися.
Адже держава планує залишити за собою контрольні пакети акцій
нових підприємств з перевезень. Крім того, ще й забезпечити собі право
на встановлення тарифів на перевезення і частину прибутків за це.
Вантажна компанія - цей оператор буде прибутковий, це точно,
навіть одразу після розділення.
Що стосується  пасажирського оператора, це буде ефективна компанія,
яка буде мати систему фінансування, яка буде складатися
з бюджетного фінансування, з фінансування регіональної влади
І також, звісно, пасажири теж будуть платити.
Досі пасажирські перевезення завжди були збитковими -
попри регулярне підвищення цін на квитки,
яке зазвичай викликало обурення пасажирів.
Фінансувати їх почасти доводилося за рахунок прибутків від вантажних перевезень.
В уряді розраховують, що пасажирські перевезення після відокремлення
не завжди будуть залежати від бюджетного фінансування
і шукають потужних іноземних інвесторів.
Глобально, каже експерт з питань транспорту Ілля Несходовський, це правильний підхід.
Головне – це зробити правильно.  І головне - знайти стратегічного інвестора,
який мав би можливість вкласти в технологію, інфраструктуру,
тим самим її покращити і знизити собівартість.
Це шлях єдиний, який можливий.
Якщо це все буде залишатися на балансі держави,
то це призведе і, в принципі, призводить до того,
що це структура, яка постійно викачує гроші, яка є неефективною.
Щоправда, саме інфраструктура буде, згідно з планами,
залишатися у власності держави.
В уряді надії покладають, зокрема, на надходження за рахунок вокзалів,
які будуть здаватися в концесію, а також, можливо, залізничних станцій,
які теж переростуть в логістичні центри.
Успіх приватизації, на думку експерта, також залежить від того,
наскільки якісно на залізниці проведуть аудит активів,
проаналізують все, від чого треба позбутися.
А також наскільки прозорими будуть конкурси на посаду керівників підприємства,
яке буде займатися інфраструктурою.
Не менш важливо, як інтереси держави будуть відстоювати
її представники в підприємствах з пасажирських та вантажних перевезень.
Необхідно змінити спосіб набору керівництва і особливо наглядової ради,
щоб вона була дійсно незалежною,  її рішення були професійними
і стосувалися того, як має розвиватися Укрзалізниця.
У Вільній профспілці залізничників ще жодного разу не бачили,
щоб керівників обирали на конкурсних засадах чи давали можливість простим робітникам
теж долучатися до стратегії управління.
Керівництво "Укрзалізниці", як і Міністерство інфраструктури,
відповідальне за здійснення приватизації, поки не звертають уваги
на громадську думку, вважає Володимир Козельський.
А приватизація в умовах тотальної корупції, на його думку, не має сенсу.
Як була корупція, ще навіть більше розростається.
То те вкрали, то те щось зробили. Немає порядку.
Я не знаю, якщо це робити, то в дуже правовій державі,
де нормально суди працюють, де нормально органи влади працюють.
Робітники залізниці сподіваються, що стратегію приватизації,
результати аналізу активів, пропозиції потенційних інвесторів
уряд, відповідно до законодавства, виставить на громадське обговорення.
Активна фаза приватизації може розпочатися вже наступного року,
після того, як Верховна Рада ухвалить увесь пакет законів,
які врегулюють приватизацію залізниці.